so something that's really funny uh every time i talk with you with supply chain is that i show
you all those researchers and then i see your name in the research and like every time but
every time like uh i think we were talking about uh the travis uh research from head of
us yeah travis ci yeah and i was talking to you about that you were like you know that
i'm on the paper and i was like you're dead justin okay
hey everyone this is techno geek here just wanted to give a quick shout out to our latest sponsor
project discovery now project discovery makes a lot of tools that you probably know of or have even
used one of them is nuclei and the latest release of nuclei is version 3.2 now 3.2 comes with a lot
of really awesome new features um two that i really wanted to highlight here for you are the
authenticated scanning and the advanced fuzzing support now for authenticated scanning it used to
be that you would have to do all your nuclei scanning against unauthenticated endpoints or you'd have to
add your cookies manually all that kind of messy no more it's all automatic you can use existing
login templates to automatically log in to your application and then you can run all your
existing nuclei templates against an authenticated part of the application now to really increase your
coverage the other that i mentioned is advanced fuzzing support now nuclei had added way back in
version 2.8 the ability to fuzz different things but now they've expanded this comprehensively across
the board so not only can you fuzz in the normal spots but you can fuzz within headers you can fuzz
within cookies you can fuzz within specific parts of the body whether that's in json or xml or form
data and so many more things so if you want to learn more about what came in nuclei 3.2 go ahead and check
out the the release blog post over at nux.gg podcast that's n-u-x.gg podcast thanks every time every time
before i start a podcast i just i start you know by jumping i just get some get some jumps out right before
we go so it's hilarious to see it maybe i need to do it on on camera um all right lupin welcome back
to the pod man you're a second time guest we also had you here on episode 37 that one was live from
japan yeah it's pretty freaking cool um now we're live from france so that's also great there we go it's
it's another location um but yeah man i excited excited to have you back on and um i think it's
very timely with all the stuff you've been releasing lately um just as right before we're recording this
episode you just released a blog post um outlining a vulnerability in uh npm yeah uh which was crazy
and we'll talk about that uh but today the focus of today's episode is going to be on um supply chain
attacks and dependency confusion which you are an expert on um so maybe we could just go ahead and
start off with give me a little bit about how you got into that space and uh tell me about depi the the
tool the amazing tool you've made uh to secure supply chain stuff yeah definitely um so how i get into
that space i think like everybody else um it's when alex burson released the his book post on dependency
confusion and uh this was amazing at the time i think i really love this vulnerability because it
was uh disrupting right it was another way of seeing scopes and we removed the domain component component
of a scope and we are more talking about packages supply chains and all those buzzwords that no one
really understands and i wanted to understand them uh so in 2021 uh i i started like creating this small
small bash uh script uh 50 lines of bash and i was pulling javascript and then exfiltrating all the
the packages from the javascript and trying to see if we could take over uh in the public registry so the
goal of dependency confusion is that uh you have two ways of uh of putting a package you have the
private that's factory and the public uh registry right and so what berson like thought was what if
i just put the same package like the same name but just a higher version on the public registry which
one the artifactory will pick and uh that's where the entire mess uh started yeah and and now you know
supply chain stuff has become a whole i mean it was really an underserved attack surface i think uh
you know prior to that whole blog post and i i was rereading that blog post in in preparation for this
podcast and it has 20 000 claps yeah on medium and i'm like whoa not 20 000 views not 20 20 000 people
that have a freaking medium account yeah you know clapping um and i was like wow okay this is a really
big thing and and i i um uh i was i was working with him on the original um you know vulnerability
that occurred uh that sort of uh spurred this whole thought and so i was cited in the paper and i remember
when it came out and it got really big a whole bunch of people that like i knew from college were reaching
out to me just like wait a second are you are you that justin garter and i'm like yeah and i just i was
really impressed by the the reach of it but now i'm starting to understand you know supply chain is a whole
whole massive attack um you know attack surface um and there's lots of different attacks that can go
along in in supply chain stuff i'm not just dependency confusion so um something that's really funny uh
every time i talk with you with supply chain is that i show you all those researchers and then i see
your name in the research and like every time but every time like uh i think we were talking about
uh the travis uh research from head of yeah travis ci yeah and i was talking to you about that you
were like you know that i'm on the paper and i was like you're that justin okay yeah man you know it's
i i think that's just two really good examples of being at the right place at the right time and
knowing the right people because um you know the travis ci stuff that was a really interesting period
in my in my bug bounty development and and um you know the work with ed overflow and and uh corbin leo
and or lorban ceo as i like to call him uh and and you know that whole that whole uh era was really
was really fun and then the you know i just kind of got pulled into that by the that crew and then the
same thing happened you know with with alex i was like okay uh let's hack on this this you know
paypal target for a live acumen and i just shared some code to alex and he was like oh wait a second
what if i totally hijacked that code and i'm like whoa um but but but i think i think there's
before we get into like all of the technical details of um supply chain attacks and dependency
confusion and that sort of thing i think there is a um i think there's some groundwork we need to set
here because most of the time when bug bounty hunters are are you know hacking we're focusing on
the web scope and this is really not um you know in some ways it's tangential to the web scope
but um this is really before all of this in the software development life cycle um so so could
you give us an overview um and i and we do have a little little graphic here we'll put up at the
screen uh um you know uh for those people walking watching on youtube about sort of the the flow of
supply chain but um could you talk a little bit about how applications are built and how they're
deployed and how what kind of attack surface we have within that environment um so the graph that you
are mentioning is coming from the salsa standard that is being constructed with the open ssf foundation
primarily founded by google and by the linux foundation so uh those are like really interesting
people uh to work with yeah yeah and um and so basically on the graph uh you see that there is
like three main uh attacked threats or attack surface uh there is the source the build and the package
so let's say that the source is everything related to the artifactories and the registries right so for
instance your jfrog is your factory and your registry will be npm pipy everything where you can set up a
uh public package right then you have the build attack surface it's everything where you are pulling
from a source and then you are building your artifact so basically all your code your dependencies uh at the
moment where you are set before deploying it right and then there is the package uh that you produce
uh so once everything is built uh you are publishing the package again and the package can come back as a
dependency for another build so that's basically how um the salsa standard is defining the the attack
surface of the entire supply chain okay so so let me let me repeat this back to you make sure i've got
it um you know we've got the devs they're writing the code you know they're in their vs code doing their
magic right and then um they're committing that into a github repo right which is also i imagine you know
a part of the source piece and um and you've also got that source um stored in in an internal environment
when we're talking about these bigger you know tech companies are stored um you know it can be in the
local version of of github it can be in a github enterprise uh you know organization or whatever it
could be on the actual um github cloud in just a private organization um and then you've also got these
sort of um artifactory well okay let me let me ask you this can you define artifactory and registry for
us because i kind of get those two terms um mixed up in my head a little bit sometimes so uh for me
an artifactory is uh where you are going to publish all your private artifacts or private uh dependencies
and it's where you are basically pulling all the packages for your internal organization okay
um so artifactory can be jfrog google has their own artifactory called the google artifacts registry
there is a code artifacts for aws um basically it's often pulled from cloud providers or there is
like jfrog their own providers right um so those packages are here to instrument and help uh create a
standard across your organization for where you are pulling the packages and then uh there is the
registries so basically an artifactory will pull all the packages from the public registries if it doesn't
exist uh on the internal artifactory so it's like a hub that factor is like a hub for all the different
uh registries and it creates like some kind of bottleneck for when you want to pull dependencies and that's
uh where it becomes interesting because once you have a central centralized piece of your supply chain you can
uh really log monitor and uh and deploy application more easily for your developers
okay okay so we've got the the artifactory that's sort of like your local version of the registry that's all for
your private packages and artifacts that are um internal to your organization like maybe your helper tools or some of the other stuff
um that are that are often used within your organization maybe your like ui components that sort of thing
um could go in there and then and then you've got the registry which is like public packages that are
um being reused by lots of different organizations and are being shared um across the whole sort of uh software development
um industry um okay and that's all all of that's a part of source and then um we go into the build area
and then um from from there we're building you know our packages bundling everything together and then
we've got um the the pack so that's where like our continuous integration stuff comes in that's like
travis ci that's um you know uh what is the uh secure ci uh get up action get up back lines yeah exactly so
that's all that um lots of attack vectors there as we know we'll cover those later and then finally we've got
the package that gets produced and that package um can be reused by other um components and that sort
of brings us back around to the beginning of the of the lifestyle or life cycle again or at least over
to the build step where those packages are being used in other in other um artifacts and and being um
sort of nested like that is that accurate yeah yeah exactly and um this attack surface is one of
the most interesting uh because we've seen in the past uh few months is a lot of vulnerability in the
ci builds like um public repositories have been here for years audited many many times uh that yeah from
one day to another you manage to pull out all the credentials because there is cash on github like
somehow uh you you can do something like that and it's crazy it's it's crazy and um basically this
attack surface why it's interesting because you can uh run remote code uh execution as a service
so here you have a bit more privileges and also depending on who can run pipelines uh you are going
to be exposed to different kind of vulnerabilities for instance um there is a lot of configuration
where every time you do a pull request to contribute to a code base there is pipelines to check
your code and so there is a remote code execution as a service here yeah which is super interesting
already yeah and and the testing infrastructure i think for all of these as well as can be sort of
built in as well so that's another piece of this that that um there could be uh vulnerabilities
introduced into and then um so then taking this the full the full step um you know after you you do
your build and you're in your um uh continuous deployment continuous integration flow yeah that's
when that code is actually hitting that prod yeah exactly and it's getting pushed out into um into the
web apps that we uh normally think about as we're hacking uh these these targets yeah um exactly okay
and and so what we want to try to attack here is any piece of that flow and um as a part of the prep for
this episode we've kind of gone through here let me see one two three four five six seven roughly seven
um sort of ways that you can attack this whole flow that we had and i'm sure we'll come up with more
as we start talking definitely um well i think i think this this podcast would be brainstorming more
than anything yeah yeah well as it always ends up to be you know whenever we chat with you so um
i'm looking forward to that um so the first thing that i kind of want to talk about uh where we can sort
of attack in this in this flow is getting us our our scope what what kind of things can we attack in
this flow and how do we identify the entities that we can attack um and and for me i think that looked
a lot like identifying these packages um uh and in repos um so so what are the most i mean obviously
you know we can look at an organization's github repo but i imagine there's more more ways to enumerate
scope for that uh can you give us a couple of those there is so many so many ways uh so uh we have
all the traditional uh wasteful uh package i call that um artifactories file i don't know if it's the
literal term for that but i i call it uh that so it's everything like package.json a jm file a yam.log
uh requirements.txt uh you can find it on the all the open source repositories of your target but um
here uh all the packages tend to be uh public in general uh you can find some private packages because
there is developers uh sometimes pushing their the internal source code and it's always really funny
and we're going to talk a bit more about those kind of techniques and how to find those internal
source code exposed uh but um there is this traditional where you put like open source right
and then uh you can go try uh to uh do some fuzzing on uh on your target so there is a lot of people
exposing their uh web route and this is where a package.json lives in general and so you can enumerate
them and uh try to to fuzz them get them back and start your dependency analysis from here that's
interesting but the most interesting techniques is when a package.json file ends up in the front end
uh directly and that's something that uh we talked a lot uh with uh the people that are doing js weasel
and they actually implemented uh a detection for that inside js result wow cool yeah uh where basically
uh there is um in the javascript somehow some libraries are just taking the package.json file
and uploading that in the front end as a string or as an object um and so you can just basically go in
the javascript pull all the strings uh in a st way and then just see the package.json no way it's so
funny and um and so that you can do on minified uh javascript actually so you don't need the dot map
file but if you want to go a little bit further you can pull the dot map file of the javascript so
basically um everything that will help you to reconstruct uh the source code and there is two
ways of checking packages here uh there is um the sources like a dot map file is a json file so there is
the source key and there there is the source code right and so in the source key you can see all the
names of uh the packages so you just pull node modules and you'll see uh some names and also webpack
for instance and you'll see then some dependencies and so here you already have all the dependencies
that are shipped in the the front end and that you can also start analysis on wow okay so so we've
got obviously we're going to be looking at um the uh open source uh repos you know on github or on
gitlab or whatever and we're going to be um assessing those thoroughly but also any any web app that is
out there you know so many of these web apps are using like webpack and that sort of structure nowadays
um and so also inside of those the the package.json file might be included um and uh you know it could
just be living in the web root as well so we always want to hit those endpoints and i've seen that time
and time again you know that that's one of the things that i think is on my quick hits list uh for
directory brute forcing is like making sure that package checking that package.json file um and
there's like a lock i think package dash lock.json file as well um that we can hit there one thing that
i wanted to add here that i think would also be a um a helpful piece is um this whole concept of
dumping the git history and this was such an amazing um i remember the moment that i learned
about this technique and this and this technique was solidified in my head i was at a live hacking
event in london with um tom nom nom and he found just a absolute mega crit on the target uh because
he he downloaded all the open source repositories and he ran this tool that he built called git dump
on it and you can find it in his um i believe it's in his actual in his dot files uh repo uh but
essentially what it does is it takes a a repository and it uses git you know git is a version uh history
to go through and dump every file that's ever existed into this massive txt file um for that
github repo right okay so um one of the things that i i thought would be pretty cool here is like
uh if they were using um certain packages in the past or uh looking at the changes to those package.json
file over time um and then maybe grabbing some of those um packages that they're no longer using
but were using in the past might give you an in into some of the dev machines or machines that
haven't been fully updated to the latest version of that open source repository um uh you know it might
be able to give you access to those if they're still pulling from that same from that same package.json
file yeah i think it's a super interesting idea because uh we had some of our clients that asked
us hey uh on your analysis we are going to talk about the tool later but it's really interesting
just to say that uh some people are like maintaining um a repository with different versions at the same
time like they're just branching all those versions and so looking at one repository on always the latest
version of course you will find some stuff but when you know that some repositories are maintained across
like many different versions from one dot x to four dot x here you can see all the different teams and
developers doing like working on some different stuff and so they asked us like to scan like every
commit ever uh on all the different branches because uh they they know that from one version to another
than it's not the same libraries that's a great point you know and they they've got to go back
and say there's a bug found in an earlier you know still supported version and if somebody's relying
on that they've got to go back and patch that version and rebuild it and reship it right and so
um you know if you're able to inject into that point whenever they need to redo that again re re
push it uh re-release that version um then there's going to be a problem something interesting is that
uh a lot of registries do not allow you to delete a version you can have like up to 24 hours to delete
it but once it's live it's live it means that if you find like a dependency issue or a supply chain issue
you need to rebuild the package and update the version so the minor version and you will just update
it but if someone outcoded the version to say i just want this specific version they will still be
vulnerable and there is a bug that we are going to talk about it later here yes where there is this
exact same problem yeah no that that's that's really pivotal and and it really speaks to the
the depth and breadth of the supply chain problem because um there there are so many people that are
like all right listen i don't want to deal with dependency hell you know i don't want to deal with
like all of this garbage that that uh you know i gotta reinstall this version and this version becomes
you know incompatible with that version i don't want to deal with all that so i just lock my my um
you know script or my program or whatever to the specific version so it always functions exactly how
i i anticipate that it will um but the problem with that is that dependencies can change over time as well
you know and and some of the pieces that have have um you know that that version might have been built
upon uh could introduce vulnerabilities or um another place we're thinking about going with this or
we're definitely going to go with with this chat as well is like what happens when static resources get
deleted um out of these packages and uh what kind of havoc that can bring um so definitely want to go
there we'll definitely get there um but i do want to take a second uh and talk about depi um so you
mentioned you know scanning across all of these different versions of the of the um of the packages uh
can you talk a little bit about how you've architected depi because i keep on wanting to ask you about tools for this
because i'm like am i going to go do this manually but then yeah but then i but then i'm like oh wait
he is the author of the tool for this so yeah um i i need to tell you a bit more about the story of depi
because i think uh like this really understand more about the architecture uh so basically as i said in
2021 i did this uh small bash script and i was collaborating a lot uh with snorlax at the time and
we were like always targeting the same uh company and our goal was to find like every kind of vulnerabilities
on that company like every bug type we wanted it right uh so that was like a that's a great goal
let's just pause for a second and appreciate that goal all right go ahead no that was a fun game
um and so uh we were on the dependency confusion route i did this uh bash script and i was just
pulling javascript file checking the the packages and on the first run of my 59 bash script we managed
to find the dependency confusion reclaim the package and at the time there wasn't any banning of the packages
and so uh it lived for one week and then we got hit and we managed to to have a remote code execution
trigger so that was like the first ever uh hit of uh debbie uh which was uh really fun at the time
it wasn't called debbie it was just called like hey dependency confusion dot sh scripts ronnie's little
script yeah exactly that's great and um and you know uh my my brother is a back-end developer and
one day uh after months of using that kind of script i i i went to him and i was like hey uh do you want
to help me like build uh the script but better because at one point i i you know i'm not a software
developer and uh he told me no he told me no classic i don't care and i'm like let's just do a proof
concept really quickly and then uh i came back uh with uh some bounties and i just uh paypal'd him
uh some bounties and he was like okay now we're talking what the heck is happening you know he's not
like in the security field so it was interesting to see like developers versus security um and so
i tricked him into building that oh my gosh that's great yeah uh at the time it was like a small
project and then we moved into a company and we don't really understand how that happened uh but it
it still did and i can just see you with like wads of cash just come here write the code you can do it
like in la i i think it was more like the technical challenge of a lot of stuff that that we were
doing but uh yeah bounties really helped too in the comments at least to get his attention yeah exactly
yeah um but but yeah we walked a lot and we had like so many different architectures at the time
we weren't weren't even saving packages in our database uh because we wanted it to be the most
lightweight possible we had like this script uh architecture in mind but then it moved to a full
back end and now to an entire uh ecosystem architecture with many microservices uh to optimize
everything um so yeah we have a lot of different uh modules and our methodology is simple we have like a
crazy idea and we're like we need to confirm this idea so we are going to build a module that we uh go in
development mode research mode of depi and just spread uh this theory across all the scopes uh that
we have right and here we are going to collect all the information of all the odd and agnostic results
that we have like stuff that aren't uh in the scope of our hipa hypothesis right we do an hypothesis we
will find that and everything that is not inside the scope we are going to dig it and that's where we find a
lot of zero days and new dependency confusion and more than the physical for your supply chain issues
so wow that's how that's an amazing structure man i love that
yeah definitely and that's how uh we we had it in mind uh depi is really a tool to help for research uh on
on like the first thing it was built for was for research and then it became a tool for companies uh
to just take the modules that they are interested in and uh scan them internally um so basically we are
going to pull all the the artifactories uh file uh all the build files and then we are going to to
scan for any supply chain uh issues in depth really okay gotcha and just before uh i know we're going
to get inundated with comments if i don't say this um depi is not an open source tool it is a software as
a service and it is enterprise focused um and so there's no way where you can go download this tool
right now this is a uh this is a uh a startup that that runny's running um so i'm just gonna put that
out there yeah um that being said uh you know you have a ton of experience architecting and developing
this tool for um detecting supply chain uh attacks and i i'm i'm curious where the 80 20 is in this in
this arena i i'm curious where um what what are the what are the 20 thing 20 of things you know of
the whole that we can do as bug bounty hunters uh to to get 80 of the results 80 of the bugs um where's
where's most of that meat living in this environment and how can we code our own scripts surrounding this
yeah essentially what i'm asking is give away your secret sauce but you knew that before you came onto
the pod you knew that i knew i knew yeah um one thing that is really interesting is that um supply
chain detection make more sense to do it internally inside the companies and that's why we built uh the
this tool to be uh for like startup company focused right because it makes more sense to go to scan from
the inside and to have the entire list of dependencies and from here start our research right uh now that
being said uh there is a lot of exposure of uh of dependencies and that the the supply chain scope
is interesting because it's not like traditional web app scope like it's not tied to a domain uh and
that's something that is really bothering uh a lot in the bug bounty when you find probabilities that are
not tied to a domain but supply chain is not tied to a domain and so one package that can exist at the scope
on an auto scope domain can still be impacting an in scope domain because there is this entire supply chain
build so uh once that you manage to detect uh any dependency there is so many stuff uh that you can
look for as we said uh you have uh the sources uh you have uh the cicd build that you want to try to
exploit and then uh there is um what's happening in the package but also how the package is being pulled
so all those areas is where i i guess the 20 percent uh okay okay we're gonna we're gonna need to build
that we're gonna need to cut that down a little bit um but i guess it makes more sense for us to go
through the list of what kind of attacks there are possible first and then sort of come back to that 80 20
questions so yeah you'd be like continue noodling i'm letting i'm letting my southern uh southern
vocabulary come out here keep thinking on that while we're um while we're going through these
which ones give you the most bang for your buck and then you know we'll we'll um talk about that
again after we've gone through the whole list um so first one obviously we've already discussed this
a little bit but it's dependency confusion and essentially my my tldr of this one is um there are ways
to make uh to make organizations download the incorrect package from a registry right that that's
the kind of that's the kind of way i i see it and uh that could be because of um there being a uh a
confusion between the the version and the name and it or like um being able to to claim a package that
has been um uh i guess abandoned or something like that or maybe one that doesn't even exist and and
it's trying to download it and it's failing um uh and so that that's the one where we sort of think
about um that was really popular with alex pearson um and the whole concept of that is pulling a package
down from um from a registry now i had a couple questions surrounding this one um obviously there's
this whole confusion of like will will it pull from the local artifactory or will it pull from the
registry right and the best way to do that i imagine would be to just try it but in order for you to try
it you have to get these payloads hosted on the registry so you've got to go to npm or whatever
you've got to sign up for a package you've got to put some package out there and here's the kicker
that package has to contain some code that will somehow let you know that it's being downloaded and
run exactly and recently if i recall correctly from our conversations uh these various registries have
been making that very difficult um could you talk a little bit about how we can host these packages
nowadays in such a way that we can test responsibly and also um test effectually uh to be able to
figure out whether this code is being run or not yeah definitely um we we've done a lot of research uh
on that uh because um like the way that we are building depi is that uh we are actually finding
vulnerabilities on bug winters and everything that is being paid will be implemented inside depi everything
that is not being paid is not implemented right wow very high signal yeah exactly and that's we want
to reduce false positives and like bs vulnerability right uh but we had a lot of pushback from programs
because uh we we couldn't host a backdoor and not only uh because registries are banning you but also
because there is a lot of legal and ethical uh problems uh with it because uh legally you don't know if
the your target is um an employee of uh the the bug bounty program that you are hacking right and so if
someone uh like call you and like hey you're backdoored my pc i and i don't know you what's happening
it's going to be really problematic so we had a lot of pushback from traders and programs just telling us
hey break the law and uh and then we'll see and i'm like i can't like in france i can't i know in
other countries you can in france i can't so we did a lot of research on how you can host uh packages
publicly and i'm i'm seeing like a um like right now you know how like uh truffle trufflesec does their
like very like dramatized videos that are just super engaging i just see but i can't do that here in
france and now it cuts to like you on a plane you know flying over to like out of the turkey or
something like that you know i love that videos oh man it's so good so good okay so yeah france has
some some rules surrounding that and i think even in the us i think there's a little bit more of a
um you know we've got sort of a blanket which is like if you're performing ethical security research then
you know there's there's sort of a caveat there and that's not really strictly defined so that makes a
lot of people uncomfortable but over the over the past couple years i've seen a lot of people push
the boundaries of what i wouldn't go for and not sort of experience any consequences so i am starting
to think that the us is a little bit more liberal with this um so but yeah we are trying to to do the
right thing and also because we are not just you know bug bounty hunters we are also a company and so
we need to to to stay ethical uh and do things correctly and so we did a lot of research and we
managed to find a technique in order to host a backdoor on the public registries without um scanners
or uh or people that are not from the organization to download the the package how we did that is uh
actually really easy uh we created our own registry and uh we we published a package a normal uh package
and then uh on the public registry uh one of the dependency is the url of our registry
oh okay all right all right so what we do is that we send like dummy packages uh like stuff just to
to to to check and uh we say to in our back end those packages if they are being pulled this is a
scanner so we can serve them a benign package but if it's not a scanner that is at our blacklist we can
just swap uh the the package on the fly and so they download a malicious version where we exfiltrate
content and that's how we did it we basically have like this uh url that is you know normal regular to
have another registry and then we check on the registry if this is a scanner or if it is not and
so we are swapping on the fly when you download uh the package very cool very cool okay so but that
requires a lot of infrastructure i'd imagine to set up a registry have all that in place so all right
well there there are some barriers to entry there for that one um if you were a bug bounty hunter
you know going after this didn't have all of this setup in place any any tips or tricks for them or
is pretty much at this point they've kind of nailed it down to the point where it's like okay well if
you're not doing this whole um independent registry with the hot swapping of the packages thing then
you're kind of in trouble yeah you're in trouble because um it has become a cat and mouse uh game
uh why registries do not have any ways to discriminate if you're a malicious actor or a bug hunter and so
it they don't they don't care about your bounty right they don't care about you succeeding your
attack and helping your people what else is new yeah they just don't want any backdoor inside the
registry which is totally normal right yeah that makes sense and so uh yeah this is a cat and mouse game
and you need to do this kind of uh hot swap um but us because we wanted to do the ethical thing we went
a bit further and now we are actually asking companies to provide their ip ranges and so we can just
do an allow list and we are sure that no one that is not from this allow list uh will uh will run
our back door um and that's how we manage to stay ethical uh while still managing to exploit dependency
confusion properly wow man i don't know that i would have gone to that the that length that's uh
that's pretty thorough but i guess i mean you got to have all of your bases covered when you're when
you're a startup um so you know that makes a lot of sense and it seems like you guys have i mean just
thinking about it from a technical perspective you've taken it really seriously and taken it about as
far as you possibly can um you know to ensure that you're that no other um parties are being
affected and it's also not like it's also not like you're dropping malware on the you know on the target
as soon as as soon as they download it so i think even just you know maybe exfiltrating the path and
the host name and you know some stuff like that it's not even that malicious for a normal user um but on
top of that you you have built in all these protections so um i think that's a really a really
responsible way of going after it and i'm a little i'm a little sad to say though that uh that that the
um there's not a really an easy way to address this from a bug bounty hunter's perspective i i've seen
a research from a company called supply shark where what they did is that um they did something very
similar with a github repo and where basically for the first week uh there will be a lot of scanners and
then they swap uh in the github repo after the first week so you need to wait for a week where you
don't know if you are going to actually uh maybe do a denial of service on your target because we are
swapping packages so maybe there are some pipelines that will just crash and you will have no way to
know that but at the same time we will avoid the scanners and you can make a backdoor leave on the
public registry uh i do not prefer this technique i think also i think is better for because for all
the ethical implications that we are behind but if really someone wants to park dependency confusion
really easily uh doing that trick with the github from supply shark we will do the trick yeah definitely
that that that's a good a good caveat maybe a good workaround for that yeah um good to know and and
so now i guess when you're actually doing your exfiltration um when you've hot swapped your
package in now you're running your quote unquote malicious very very benign malicious code um uh how
are you exfiltrating are you doing it over http or are you doing it over dns like the original
dependency confusion post outline yeah for now we are doing uh over http uh but it can be done to dns
without any problem and i think it's better to do it uh to dns because there will be a lot of um egress
and firewalls that will block you uh from uh expirating to http but the truth is uh if you manage to pull
our registry uh you can also uh ping it back so i sure sure so i i i don't that's why we didn't do the dns uh
path because once you you pull from the the public registry uh that that's it but this is interesting
when the factory is actually pulling your package and so the factory has the right to go through the
internet but not uh your uh your machine your end your end level machine okay that makes sense so it's
also sort of like a okay you've got this um artifactory server that's reaching out and then dropping it back
down to the user so it's sort of like that same you know it's one of the things i like about dns as an
exfiltration method is like the whole recursive nature of it right like you know i'll just send
out my payload and that's going to get you know bumped from one dns server to another dns server to
another dns server to another dns and then it's going to land on my on my machine and it allows you
to exfiltrate out of really you know wonky scenarios but you do at least have one layer of that with these
sort of artifactory based things because you've got that artifactory in between you and the end user
um and the artifactory of course is going to have much more uh liberal egress rules um so and so
that's that that's cool i'm wondering if there's any room for a combination of the both where it's
like okay um we can do a sort of benign dns callback just like ah this popped and then also you know have the
registry run yeah i i think i think definitely there is a lot of exfiltration uh techniques are
possible um i don't think that in a bug bounty situation or even us as a company we we need those
uh because if you manage to pull one package uh like the the chances are really slim that you went
through an artifactory that has the rights but your computer do not have the the the right so it's possible
that a lot of companies are setting up like that but i haven't have that issue that that often but
also yeah but also you wouldn't see that issue if you did have it that's that's true so there is some
truth here but uh again on the ethical thing uh if if you actually try to dns there is a lot of as you
said dns servers that can see what you are exfiltrating yeah and and so i do it over https uh
uh just to have this kind of layer encryption because you know i'm paranoid with that kind of
stuff nah nah i couldn't tell um that's great man that's awesome you get you're really checking all
your boxes and um dotting all your i's and crossing your t's there so i think that's that's really good
um so let's so that's the basic sort of um dependency confusion stuff and i'm sure that there's a lot of
nuance to that you know in various systems you know for uh nuances for for uh pip for npm and that
sort of thing but let's let's talk about a more a broader range um or a more a bigger concept when it
comes to supply chain which is maintainer attacks and the whole concept behind this um for those not
familiar with it is that you know each one of these repositories that we're trusting uh these packages
that we're trusting with our our code flow um are maintained by a bunch of unpaid open source you
know maintainers that just love the community um and do it because of that but um because they're not
getting paid because it's not they're actually their responsibility or any skin off their back
sometimes they may stop maintaining the package um and there's a lot of ways that you can uh compromise
a maintainer account and thus compromise the code um so could you talk about a couple of those
techniques that that could result in a package compromise it's really funny because one of the
first techniques that i've seen uh about this was right after dependency confusion occurred uh or a bit
before i don't remember but i've seen it right after it was uh matthew bryant uh from snap in classic
classic dude that did the research on how he managed to take over and one of angular uh dependencies
uh through uh an attack that was like oh my gosh yeah well what it did is that uh you know the the
open source community and developers really like to have custom domains right it's really cool uh to
to have like i don't know you're justingardner.com or renorator.com domain somebody's somebody's
squatting on justingardner.com really i don't own that man like and they're not even using it the last
time i checked so have you tried to send them an email and buy it back you know maybe someday if
i'm super loaded i'll be like hey man i'll slide you a 20 for that 20. i love it um yeah but no devs
definitely love fancy domains yeah and they swap them pretty often with new like tlds coming out and
stuff like that too exactly and so a lot of um those domains are used uh for for their main uh emails
uh but a lot of people forget to renew domains and but uh what's interesting points us on npm is
that uh even if your domain do not exist you can still log in uh just if you don't if you have mfa
you can't log in but if you have your 2fa they are not really going to check your your domain anymore
and so a lot of maintainers in the open source community do not own their domain anymore but are
still using the email as a way to log in dude but when i say a lot it's a lot and there there is a
research paper uh that that came and i think i'm going to drop the link so you can put that in the
description we'll find it about the weak links of um supply chain and they said that domain
takeover is a huge wingly weak links and they did a lot of statistics uh on that and it was appealing
uh to to see that um and so the the the idea behind the attack is that your domain uh can be uh taken
over so you buy it back and uh you do a forgot password and you can log in again classic man classic
route the the forgot password and and man i'm i'm surprised that more of these um registries aren't
enforcing 2fa uh because i feel like that's just a no-brainer like if you are a if you're the
maintainer of a package that has like you know x thousand installs or weekly installs or whatever
it should absolutely be mandatory for 2fa to be enabled yeah yeah i actually npm and pipey are uh
starting to to do that more and more i know that github is also uh doing that but there is a lot of
maintainer that are just setting up to mfa uh by default so we we are on the same problem uh all
over again and um but but yeah it's it's a really interesting attack surface um and there is like a
question when when you use that on backbunty like who is the owner of that and that question of
ownership of the supply chain uh we might have need to talk about that earlier but no no no i we got time
let's go but uh no one talks about that yeah yeah like who owns the software supply chains are the
like the to the company using the packages uh the developers using the packages like as end users or
are the maintainers responsible of that and like if there is an issue who who is at fault everyone no
one and that's a problem like because we are putting figures at one another on that subject and no one
really knows who owns the supply chain yeah dude that's a huge problem because it because also like
wow yeah if i if i have the ability to attack a you know an asset that's in scope in a bug bounty
program a lot of programs have these like and anything else you can prove that we own you know
clauses or whatever right um am i authorized to attack that or am i not authorized attack that because
it's not you know even though they're running this code is it their code now it's the maintainer's code
but also is it though you know it's like that's super tricky yeah and even in case of a cyber attack
it's really easy for a company to say oh no that it's not our fault it's the the maintainer that is
underpaid in a third world country that is at fault and you're like what the heck it's still inside your
code base you need to secure yourself about that and that's like really interesting because um european
regulation you know european and regulations love that uh they put an answer to that and they said uh
if you are uh targeted in the suppression attack you are responsible because you were the one uh that
pulled the code and ultimately put that in your code base i'm clapping right now for the people that
are not on youtube no that that's excellent and man i i do you know i'm american i i'm from america
and i love america but um man uh europe really does have some has been doing a great job sort of leading
the way on some of these things and there's a lot of things that europe messes up with their regulations
uh but uh when it comes to making people take security seriously it seems like they are on the right
path which is really cool i'm going to to give some kudos to america because they were the the first i
think that had s bombs so software bill of materials including dependencies uh listing uh mandatory uh for
every companies and critical services so um having an s bomb is a really already like a cool step to
see to have observability on a supply chain um but it's not enough when you know how much attack surface
there is yeah no absolutely and i think when you build that you know s bomb as software bill of
materials yeah um it it opens your eyes to how how many packages you're actually relying on as well
which is really cool um i did i did want to add one thing here i did google it really quick because
as i was as the words were coming out of my mouth ah npm should enforce 2fa first yeah like yeah they did it
yeah they did it actually in 20 in 2022 actually so it's been a little while um but it's only for
packages uh with more than 1 million weekly downloads or over 500 uh dependence um is what this initial
and maybe they've changed it since then but uh this initial post from two years ago um shows that it's
that and that's kind of a high bar i thought i thought that it was for everyone actually okay well maybe
maybe they've they've changed it um since then but i'm glad to see at least they made they made some
change i know that mfa is mandatory but maybe 2fa with an authenticator app or everything is for more
than one million maybe but still really interesting that yeah okay all right well i i won't get too
yeah unfortunately joel's off today so i my i i normally i would just say joel i wonder about
the body blah like and then he would just be instantly nerd sniped and then i would
he would just research it and then interject five minutes later with the nuanced answer but
um unfortunately he's not here today okay um he's off this week so we'll we'll leave that to the
listeners to see uh to educate me in the youtube comments which will no doubt occur um so okay all
right great so that covers maintainer attacks there's lapsed domains but there's also one one note
that i wanted to add on maintainers is that uh from our test a uh big size company uh in france we call
that next uh 40 companies so the big big startups uh they have in average between 200 000 to 400 000
packages internally uh and i'm not talking just about like our first dev packages but like with the entire
uh chain so like the entire debt right those 400 000 packages uh has a direct impact impact on the
supply chain but now each package is maintained between one two to three person so you can easily
have more than one million people uh being able to affect your code base and those numbers are insane
because something that i said to a lot of people i go in the streets i can trust 100 people how do
you trust one million of one million maintainers dude that is absolutely crazy um wow dude man just
hearing about the the vastness of this it gets a little overwhelming for me you know thank goodness
i'm not in corporate security because like if i were a blue teamer i just like and even as even as
like a sas business owner it's like man this is such a it's really something you have to allocate
for cost wise too because the amount of resources that it takes and i'm sure depie will help with
this once it you know it hits the mainstream as well but like the amount of resources it takes to
thoroughly vet and secure that whole flow and knowing that just one slip up can result in compromise of a
of a build machine which is the thing that has your secrets that has like you know all of this i mean it's
just it's not it's not great dude yeah that's terrifying and something that like i also have
had a lot of pushback with companies when we're reporting supply chain issues they're like oh but
there's a low probability of exploitation but the risk is always remote code execution so how do you
assess that kind of stuff like when you know that the risk is highly low but when like why is the risk
low i feel like the probability of exploitation is highly low but the risk is like the impact is
super high but how do they even factor i mean what do you mean the probability of exploitation like
are we saying like this is too complicated for attackers to figure out because we know that that's
not the case more like the probability of a developer actually pulling the the package because
like sometimes the artifactory is really well set up but imagine a developer forgetting to put their dot
npm rc file and forgets to go through the artifactory as a company you can't like if you have like 2000
developers for instance how do you know that they are configured properly on their machine you can't but
also at the same time they should be configured properly so it's true that there is a low probability
that one developer may sleep up but when they do the impact is always huge yeah no that's that's
terrifying um and and actually it makes me think um you know i think it would be a really cool piece
of like marketing material for you to release that'd be really helpful for the community to do like a a
cheat sheet for companies on like how to secure your supply chain like go claim these packages like do
you have this in your artifactory yeah go claim this just in case somebody you know slips up or something
like that um because i imagine there's a lot of sort of defense in depth techniques that you could do
that would um prohibit some of these attacks from happening because my response if i'm if i'm
playing from the program side on to what you just said is like okay well um how do i fix that how do
i fix a developer slipping up developers always going to slip up it's just like fishing right well the way
you fix that is you one make sure they can't uh slip up too bad by you know claiming those packages and
two you make sure that your you know development settings are set up with secure defaults um but i
think going that extra layer could be really really helpful yeah and i think that there is a lot of like
those can be fixed like uh it's not like we are doomed and that the world will collapse because you
are using a supply chain uh you can fix all those um those holes in the supply chains and um and of
course i think it would be a great resource to provide uh guidance on how to fix these issues and
also how to assess them but it has been a really long debate with a lot of different programs on how
to assess in the bug bounty ram and paradigm uh those supply chain issues because again we don't have a
scope anymore but the impact is always great so how would you assess that dude it's got to be it's
got to be impact based man i mean at the end of the day you you've got to you've got to look at
these scenarios and you've got to say okay listen if if you know lupin is attacking this you know one
off little little dev uh you know environment over here but then it's compromising a server that has
access to these aws keys that give you the ability to interact with prod and like of course i mean that's
the end of the freaking world yeah like the keys of the kingdom yeah exactly and and we know that it
happens all too often and that's and i think i think from the bug bounty side obviously doing your
your due diligence and really understanding what an attacker could do from from that perspective
takes time and takes effort but i think that's where you kind of separate the wheat from the chaff
there as far as programs goes you separate the good programs from the bad programs and the ones that
are really um and not necessarily the bad programs you know i should be a little bit more understanding
if there's anything these uh you know program versus hacker debates uh that we've had in the pod over
the past couple months has taught me it's like you know a lot of these people are severely understaffed
these organizations are severely understaffed and uh just cannot get the amount of people that they
need to do their job properly of course and yeah that's why i'm bringing those debates on on the table
because as a bug hunter i want to be paid uh but yeah i need also to understand the ram and um and
that's a way in black bounty uh to re do more bounties and get more rewards is by understanding what
the program needs from you for instance the email takeover to domains some programs accept that uh it's
rare but uh it really depends on their maturity but a lot of programs will tell you it's not our
responsibility uh the dev like it's the maintainer fault and i i mean in some ways they are right
like they're not going to claim domains that are not theirs right uh but at the same time it will
impact their supply chain uh at one point so it all boils down to your maturity your budget and uh how you
want to treat the the research community more than bug hunters is really more about the research and like
novel techniques and how do you see them and appreciate them uh inside your bug program i think
if it if it expands your understanding of your own infrastructure and you make remediations based off
of that i think you should pay for the scenario the worst case scenario if you do not have the the
resources to do your full due diligence and and i think that's painful for a lot of um a lot of bug
bounty programs um but at the end of the day we all know what should be happening which is that you should
be doing a a thorough assessment of these threats and then if but if you don't have the manpower and
the staffing to do it you know maybe split the difference with the researcher at least but just
don't categorize these as lows or mediums because they're the the impact is really is really large and
and we all know anybody who's ever performed an external to internal pen test knows that once you get
a lot of data you're doing a lot of data you're doing a lot of data you're doing a lot of data
and you're doing a lot of data you're doing a lot of data you're doing a lot of data you're doing a lot
of data you're doing a lot of data you're doing a lot of data you're doing a lot of data you're doing
a lot of data you're doing a lot of data you're doing a lot of data you're doing a lot of data
you're doing a lot of data you're doing a lot of data you're doing a lot of data you're doing a lot of data
data you're doing a lot of data you're doing a lot of data you're doing a lot of data you're doing a lot of data
into uh from other side projects or something like that and then giving an attacker access to their
like github account or their um you know registry account and allowing the attacker to move from
there um so is that something you're also you know you've also seen and something you're scanning for
within depi yeah uh we are still in a research uh module uh right now so uh we have this uh beta we
call the frontline uh access uh that that will not have those uh secret scanning but we we are
researching more and more trying to remove all those false positives but definitely uh something
really interesting uh to see because like even in the ci uh compromission uh realm uh there is a lot of
developers that set up their own cicd pipeline that will use their npm token that is tied uh to
to their entire organization or for their company and if they don't secure their pipeline you are
going to compromise the overall uh company so once you manage to find a package then you need to find
the github associated to the package with the pipeline or the gitlab then once you find that you
need to find all the maintainers that can commit code inside once you find those maintainers you find
all their projects all their pipelines and you scan back again oh my gosh and that's something that
we want to do and uh that that we are uh actually starting to to do but that spidering is like how
much in depth we go that's the question i i imagine that's actually pretty computationally
expensive too like when we're talking about the network effect of all this like like you know you've
got all of these maintainers let's say there's a million maintainers and then each of them has you
know a hundred repos or whatever and you and then each of these repos have like years of git history
right and it's like wow now we're having to sift through like terabytes of code to try to find that
one place where some developer you know put a token put a token or committed an ssh key or something
like that of course um we we have some technical uh challenges here and uh we have a lot of fun uh
with them yeah there is a lot of stuff that we thought that were impossible uh for instance um
related to depth because uh by the end of the day we we're like it's exponential uh and uh and we have
a lot of computing problem but uh to different uh techniques we managed to uh make one request that
we're taking like three minutes to analyze per package we managed to make it like five seconds
oh wow okay wow five seconds optimization going into this yeah but it's already long though but uh
we're getting there we're getting there and you're writing this in rust too right so this is not like
you're all of this is what yeah definitely yeah yeah and it's not like all this is running in like
python or like you know some some much slower language you're trying to do this at a really optimized
level and i think that's the right the right choice from the beginning now hearing about the scale
and i we had a little bit of a debate on this the last time we discussed your we did like a little
brainstorming um you know meeting for your product and i was like man like why you got to write this
in rust but now that i'm sort of understanding the the the breadth of all of this yeah um it's an
absolutely massive undertaking so um that makes a lot of sense man okay so the maintainer attacks we've got
those um now this is a i guess this is sort of a complicated question so people that are trying to
build out these software build materials right this this list of dependencies that they have for their
given software i was thinking like okay wow this is actually going to be really tricky like we got
to kind of nuancedly you know map out everything else but then i realized all we have to do is clone
it down and then just run npm install right like yeah you can i mean that will pull that's why these
node modules uh folders are just so like ridiculously massive is they pull everything down right so i mean
is is a good way to do this to actually just clone the repo do npm install and then just like find you
know find dot and just look at all of the packages yeah i think this technique is not as scalable uh
because when you have a repository that is two gigs and then you you see all the the the dependencies
uh it becomes uh horrible uh but um you can optimize a lot of things for instance github expose an
api for the s bomb so every oh yeah that's awesome yeah every public uh uh github repository has an s bomb
associated and that you can call with an api no way yeah and if there is i did not know that and if
there is a log file uh you can actually have all the the packages back dude this is so this is so cool yeah
i really appreciate i did not know that this existed this is really this is not like a secret source of
our scanning but um really helped me a lot uh when i was building all the tools um and yeah i think
that that would be the best way uh yeah well especially for us you know for for for people
looking for the you know 80 20 situation here um that's really cool and and i think stuff like like
me not knowing about that shows you know how how all there are all these little pockets of of info
that we kind of need to be able to address the supply chain thing um correctly but i'm really
glad that github uh went ahead and and went after that because uh that's a great level to solve it at
right any almost everything ends up in a github repo at some point and so um and i imagine gitlab
will put something together or already has something yeah github already is doing the something and they
also have uh artifactories per repository so one repository can expose one artifactory that is just
for the repository oh wow yeah it's really interesting and since gitlab is open source you can see how
they are pulling packages and stuff like that and there is a lot of uh weird thing that they are doing
and it's so fun to see the shortcuts that artifactories are taking to be compliant with the protocol of
uh npm and stuff like that and like yeah most of the calls are mocked which is so funny oh man
i i imagine that's a whole a whole you know good scope for you to go after when when looking at at
these um in the github enterprise and in gitlab as well we we we can talk about that a little bit but
if you really want to find that 20 i think more than checking the dependencies uh go check the
artifactories but because they all have a bug bounty program and once you find uh artifactories uh there
is so many bugs why because supply chain is infinitely complex and so there are so many use cases even
within an organization like one developer can a developer remove a version no on the npm registry
it's not allowed but on the factory it's allowed and you don't have any logging and monitoring uh so
you can replace a version backdooring the version that already exists wow but and you don't have any
way to know which developer did that uh that's a problem and once you you step back and you do not
see that as a web app scope but more about a supply chain hub uh you'll find many more vulnerabilities
that you may think is a low vulnerability from a business perspective but always ends up in a remote
code execution and so yeah the stakes here are very high i've been hacking artifactories for the past year
i i think and uh the attack surface is so big for one single endpoint because of all the supply chain
implication so you have one endpoint just the one pulling the packages and you can hack it in so many
different ways because for instance they didn't think about uh ranges versions uh or they they didn't
think about a lower case or uppercase or unicodes and so you have like confusion here which is so funny
to see yeah dude normalization bugs just all sorts of all sorts of craziness i imagine you know one one
layer of url encoding missed you know across this whole thing could could mess up a bunch of stuff too
because those are proxies artifactories are proxies you also have ssrf in some ways yeah wow that's
that's nuts man there's so many so many ways to look at that problem um okay so sub-dependency mapping
we got the software build materials we got our npm install that sort of thing um so the next area
that i sort of wanted to go to was this and we kind of touched on this already but attacking the
artifactories and registries right there's a great way to go after that like you mentioned is doing a source
code analysis of the artifactories they've got bug bounty programs going after the way that they
deal with this but also it's possible for us to attack the registries yeah um and and so i know you
have a bug here that you are going to share with npm which i think would be really really cool and i
it just went out uh i it just went out like right before we recorded two hours ago that's awesome that's
great and so um we'll be covering it right on the pod uh just a couple days we'll be releasing this
pod later this week so um you know we should be a pretty fresh coverage on this but uh talk about
your experience hacking on these registries themselves and and what kind of impact uh and
what kind of attack vectors they have yeah uh so uh the bug that we we disclosed today was on npm
npm is owned by github i know that a lot of developers or tech people do not know that but npm by
name is microsoft in some ways uh oh my gosh yeah multiple layers of acquisition there yeah exactly
and so um we were doing like a uh sub module for dpi again in research mode and and our question was
like how we can uh you know impact the availability of the packages of our clients and because they have
like artifactory we're like hey what if we do cash poisoning on the artifactory we denied the artifactory
if they are public and we just you know dust all the the pipelines of our clients that would be a
really fun vulnerability right yeah that would be nuts actually and i love that you went for
availability as well that you didn't forget about the a and the cia triad because um you know it makes
a lot of sense to go after confidentiality getting access to that source code integrity obviously has rcu
based impacts but availability i think would not be one of the things that would pop into my head
immediately when i'm thinking about this but it has such a massive impact on the scope because
it breaks all these builds um definitely and and cache poisoning is the perfect attack for this because
um you know they have to if these packages are being downloaded millions and millions and millions
of times they have to be cached or else the the cpu load is going to be way too much um so tell me
tell me how you ended up being able to exploit that yeah so we developed a small script integrated that to
to depi and uh we forgot to remove the public registries uh and so we did the first scan and
then result uh registry.npmjs.org is vulnerable and i was like no that's no i'm not trusting my script
that was the first run and i'm not kidding like this is twice in in our research where we had like a
first hit uh so a lot of miracles are happening man like seriously like one the script works the first
time you run it two it works on the freaking biggest registry out there and so i thought it was a false
positive right and i i go to check manually and it triggers we have a cache poisoning if you set a header
at the moment you do the get request uh to to to take the package uh it will create a 404 and this
404 will be cached on the part like the prod registry and like it's not even a natifactory it's it's like
the registry right and um and so dude you must have been so freaked out when it worked you're you're like
i can't i can't believe this man so i i didn't write that in the article but i i really stepped back from
the computer closed everything and just uh went in my bed and just you know stared at the ceiling for a
little while yeah exactly i was like it's funny no i it's not possible i always you know we talk
about uh finding bugs and stuff like that on the pod and and one of the one of the things i always do
that i mentioned a couple times is as soon as i find a bug just step back a little bit take a breath
and then run to my wife as fast as i can say look i just found this amazing thing and it's like no i
haven't reported it yet no i i i have i haven't double checked it yet even you know and then you know half
the time it's like a false positive and and she's like having to pull me out of the the pit of
despair or whatever after i thought i had a mega crate and now it's not but i i actually do that with
a lot of uh bug hunters friends where right right you know i've sent to you some of those crazy oh my
gosh i love those moments man dude i found that and like oh no no it was a typo yeah i love your i love
your um i love your messages i found it it's crazy it's got that thought uh wait a second but wait
maybe it'll no no that's not gonna work you know it's the life of a bug hunter man the life of a bug
yeah but but when we hit something we're really happy we are we are and it shows the passion for
it so um it keeps us coming back for more yeah but but here i was a little bit more freaked out
because i knew the implication of a software software supply chain bug at that scale like
if you manage to deny a package you can like basically impact the entire javascript ecosystem
and yeah bring down pipelines yeah and developers machine and like just say hey tomorrow is a
holy day for everyone right you're not developing anymore oh my gosh dude could you imagine the havoc
that would cause if you like dosed like express or something like that exactly like a friday night
or something or like when do people deploy probably thursday you know the dasa doss express on thursday
that'd be terrible man that will be so funny i think and a lot of like dev team security i mean
incident response would be like what the heck is happening yeah yeah all of a sudden this package just
expressed just 404s on npm it's like oh no we know the way they think in incident response is like oh
we did something wrong and then you check and then you're like oh no they did something wrong like
wait a minute how that happens it was dns yeah they did something wrong yeah i was thinking about
the facebook bgp bug yeah like everyone was freaking out like oh my dns is not working it's like oh
no it's facebook no worries yeah man and there's that's another interesting area there is if you could
attack it at the dns level as well i imagine things would be cached but yeah that's an interesting
approach let's write that down try it and then we do a pod again might have to bleep that who knows
whatever yeah um uh so the other the other sort of um attack factor that i had in dos makes a bunch
of sense here but also if there was an idor in this sort of environment it would absolutely be
terrible um have you done any of that more granular testing on these on these uh organizations or
mostly are you focusing on the bigger ecosystem for now i've done it on the artifactories uh level okay
uh and not on the registry uh because like i've sent uh this bug uh for github npm and uh they give me
a 500 dollar brunzi for like oh my gosh dude yeah and i was like really surprised because uh they said oh
no it's a distributed denial of service and i'm like i managed to reproduce it from a machine of
course the caching wasn't like for every backends but you know you you are still affecting a huge part
of the traffic if you manage to exploit it correctly and they said no it's a ddos so it's not uh in our
scope of the program it's more abuse and i was like oh my gosh dude yeah i mean you've got a you've got a
uh a screenshot right here in your blog post that like says npm install and then you're downloading the
the the package and then you know you can see it goes through successfully and then just like what
what is this like a one minute later not even one minute later you you try to reinstall it again and
it and it says no there's a 404 not found like how could they how could they argue with that i mean uh i
i i didn't really understand and i've wrote in the blog uh my you know why i was bothered about
this entire assessment i have nothing against the gilbert security team that amazing people again i
uh i will tell you again that there are really amazing people but the overall assessment of this
report was a bit of a mess i would say yeah i agree and i i don't know if you've seen the timeline
but um what they did is that uh they said it was an internal duplicate at the beginning uh and then
uh it's a couple of months later they traced it uh and then a couple of months later they closed it
as informative uh six months later i sent no ronnie i'm so sorry man i know you told me lately you're a
little burnout on bug bounties but and it don't make total sense given this experience because this is
not how it's supposed to work when you're doing supply chain uh it has it happens a lot uh that
that kind of assessment uh but um yeah i and then six months later i think i i send like hey can we
disclose the vulnerability they said oh yeah and we can help for the technical analysis of your write-up
and i was like awesome but they didn't fix the vulnerability right they didn't fix it and they told
me we are allowing the disclosure and so i sent them the draft report and they told me hey we're
fixing the vulnerability now yeah of course i imagine so but but my my goal with disclosure
wasn't like to pressure or anything i just wanted to talk about like a super cool vulnerability that
i really loved uh but i was really disappointed about the assessment and the fact that you know one
year later one year after reporting the fixing the vulnerability is for me like really weird yeah
it's super weird especially when the impact is so is so wide and i i'm looking through here and i think
they mentioned in here that like there was some um inconsistency with the caching servers it seems
like where like uh because only yeah yeah every every fourth or fifth request was being dropped but
i'm like when it's expressed that you can you know like one you know every fourth or fifth request is
like millions of requests like why is this a problem to put some numbers express is 30 millions
install per week uh and on the latest version it's 12 millions install so every time there is a latest
version in one week it hits 12 million installs and and so even though you have one fourth of the
requests uh that that are getting denied one fourth of the 12 millions is that's huge insane dude yeah that
uh man this is this i mean like you said i i love the get up team too there has been some
difficulties with them in the past just to be perfectly clear and in my experience they've
they've come around on it and they normally um you know after you have to talk to them and you you
know go through the whole impact scenario they've paid out really really generously for me in the past
but i imagine you know sometimes it doesn't always end up quite that way but i hope after this
article was released in the the general security you know industry says oh you know this is bad
um that exactly you know they come back and make it right on this because uh this is a serious bull
man again i my goal is not to put pressure with the disclosure like if people want to to say something
publicly they they will tell us something publicly it's not my problem like i really wanted to talk about
the research and more like hey on on depi we have a sub module that will check for our ability too
uh which was like the the the main goal of uh this research to be able to demonstrate that a supply chain
attacks when it comes to other bt impact can be huge yeah yeah clearly no that that's that's amazing
um all right so we've covered attacks on the artifactories and on the registries maintainer attacks
the last one we sort of alluded to ci related bugs um there's there's some research out there that you
guys can go and uh and dive into by ed overflow and this guy named justin gardner never heard of him
yeah yeah um so there's that and there's also um i guess we will touch on one of these because i i
also wanted to mention this um last time or last time we had johan on on the pod he he mentioned this
whole concept of hijacking a a flow uh a ci flow um inside of git lab and i think that that's a really
interesting approach and there's lots of ways to do that uh but i think that's another really um
important part of this whole um supply chain attack vector concept um because these things are getting
more and more complex as as they go and uh and there's more and more opportunities for for people to
inject their their input into it whether it be a pull request whether it be like a lapsed domain
or s3 bucket or that sort of thing um and then gain control of these ci flows and then leak
important secrets and that sort of thing um so so yeah what are your thoughts on that whole on that
whole front and how is depie addressing this issue it's amazing i i i i i love this area of research uh
there is one researcher that i've been doing a lot of work on that and his name is adnan and uh it's
amazing to see all of his uh ci bug and i'm really impressed by how many uh bugs we can find in this
attack surface and again it's one functionality but the attack surface is huge and definitely
something on the roadmap of depie for now we're focusing on software artifacts but builds as we
said this is the beginning is an important component of the software supply chain and is the natural uh
process to go through builds at one point with depie uh we found a couple of vulnerabilities uh
related to ci but more like github uh overall yeah yeah there's lots of overlap there because
i mean at the end of the day the stuff is going to be present in in github uh because that's where
the the ci is running from so if you're just doing this you know if you're assessing from a github level
you can see a lot of that and i think the only exception to that really is like the the stuff
that's being injected directly um at the ci level you know the the tokens and the api keys and that sort
of thing um and then also the logs that are generated from the uh the the ci themselves and and that's
where you know that research that we did with travis ci came in and and where i found an rce a while
back it was actually that's awesome one of one of my first rces was um grepping through uh logs for
this uh crypto website or on their ci um and finding out that they had echoed out their private key in one
commit and i just used that private key to just log in as root to the server that's awesome and it should
have been a 10k bounty but it was like they're like um it's a 1k bounty by you know classic classic
crypto program uh bs but yeah i feel like there's definitely some difficulties in in the sort of
supply chain bug bounty ecosystem on getting them to actually pay the vulnerability some for some reason
well one technique that i really like um for now i'm not focusing on um exploiting the ci but more about
the results of the ci and one technique that i i i love is that to find all the metadata around the
the pulling of the packages so you are going to see the the traffic of the which artifactory they they
use and so and sometimes you can also find it in inside the javascript exposed uh publicly like which
artifactory they're using so basically what i do is that i copy the domain of of this private artifactory
that we can find in ci uh and we can find in public javascript usually if i find it in in in ci it's
because norlax uh gave me the ci he's classic amazing hunter uh and really good uh with ci too so
often he gives me the the factory but then i go on github and put path uh colon
um and then package dash lock dot json and then i put the artifactory domain because what's happening
in the log file you see all the all the the artifactories and where is the tar dot jz ball like
the table right and so you see the domain and so every log file you know it comes from a developer of the
organization and that's where i managed to leak source code of like private source code not even packages
right source code of uh of many organizations insane and dev on developers uh accounts that weren't even
inside the organization it's just like their like test account and they did a a a pushed internal source
code and there you you managed to find a lot of different stuff credentials um you can assess like
do code review you can already report it for some company it's uh already good enough to to report that
kind of bugs um and so that's like my technique to uh find expose the source code and go through the
artifactory and the build results that's that's an awesome tip and and i think also getting your hands on
any sort of enterprise source code is just so nuts like i remember that that initial dependency
confusion blog post you know mentioned that we were that i handed him some source code from from paypal
the source code that we found that was actively being used in paypal's environment leaked secrets in
it that we were able to use to encrypt and decrypt stuff um oh and it led to like over 50k in bugs
uh just from being able to see these little pieces of middleware here and there that were like
popping up around huge um and it's like wow just getting your hands on any any piece of that that's
actually running allows you to make such more nuanced attack factors um towards that target so
that's really really essential that can be taken more broadly in the supply chain and you just um check
all the the internal uh domains of a company and then you search them uh on github uh and uh that could be
also a really fun uh thing to do yeah yeah i think i think that's really um anytime you see
here's here's the secret sauce for how we did it with with paypal actually it's been years i'll just
kind of um you know uh share the secret sauce here um essentially you know in in paypal's environment
there's a bunch of different little microservices right that that uh are powering the paypal app
and each there's a way i won't disclose it all but there's a way that you'll see these around you
know in the in the responses of the requests or when errors are triggered or whatever um and then you can
take these little microservices names and you just put those bad boys into github
and you know anytime and those microservice names correlate to like package is for the code
and so you put them into github and then you you know search round look through everything and uh
you know you may if you get lucky um uh pop some some internal source code uh and and i think a lot
of other companies have similar structures uh i'm not sure if those little package names or host names
or microservice names are getting leaked as much but i imagine i know on the back end that they have
similar structures to that so um anytime you see a unique string that seems to correlate to the
infrastructure behind the application you're attacking always take that to github and and run a
search on it because um you'd be super surprised uh on what kind of stuff definitely um all right dude
let's see uh okay so the npm cache poisoning bug super cool the tldr of that one was that you were able to
go to attack the npm registry where they're actually downloading the package files directly
and uh you know we won't specify through what method but you're able to somehow provide a uh a
um additional piece of information in that request that makes it go to a 404 and that 404 gets cached
and then when anyone else tries to request that page again uh they get the 404 instead of access to
that you know targz file or whatever it is um crazy bug i really hope that gets addressed and we don't
have to deal with that in the ecosystem um let's talk about the next one that you wanted to share on
the pod which is the grafana npx uh confusion yeah oh that's uh that was uh really funny uh so first of
all i think uh this needs to be said uh the graphana security team is one of the most mature uh security team
i've ever worked with and not just that material they're wholesome they're so funny to work with
and uh it has been a pleasure uh to send them about yeah i had the same experience with them back in
in 2020 with the grafana ssrf they were they were awesome and so uh what happened is that i was again
depi research mode uh and this time i wanted to find a bug on gitlab uh cut source uh because i have
a friend that challenged me to do so and uh and i was like okay let's do it but when analyzing um gitlab i
managed to find like a dependency uh that is called graphana dash toolkit um that was uh not claimed uh
publicly and uh this boils down to um um basically graphana toolkit is not a package it's a binary but there
is a package manager called npx uh which is from and the same npm team and npx stands from uh node package
execute and instead of uh of being a manager and trying to install i've seen this okay i know what
you're talking about instead of being a a manager that will just install the package it will run a binary
directly okay so these are like for like command line applications or whatever that you're going to
use to supplement some you know maybe use grafana toolkit or whatever to add a user to grafana or
something like that from the command or something yeah exactly and so uh what's interesting when npx is
that uh if you do npx a package and you do not have the binary name inside your computer it will pull from
the public registry and then uh just install the package and will run it so you don't do not have
to do an npm inside command uh before but there is a problem it's the npx takes a binary name but the
public registry is packages name so there is a confusion on npx side between both of them basically
if you have like graphana dash toolkit was like the name of the binary but the name of the package
was at graphana slash toolkit and so that's not good a lot of companies in their uh docker file uh ci cd
uh or even a documentation uh was writing npx graphana dash toolkit but this package didn't exist so what
i did i claimed it and every time that you do npx graphana dash toolkit so i don't know i claimed it
that's great i love it and and you you you are uh basically uh downloading uh this binary that i've
claimed on npm uh what's really interesting uh from from this bug and that we need to say from grafana
team it didn't affect their source code and actually all their ci cd that we're using npx graphana
toolkit because there were some were archived uh from a long time ago but the open source community
was still using uh this command because they usually install the package first and then running the npx
command sure but if you do not have the binary installed and that can go really fast uh then you
have the same dependency confusion and you have a remote execution but what's interesting here it's not
on the artifactory level anymore it's directly on the package manager and that's a realm of research
that we haven't seen much before ah okay at the at the i see yeah we are not trying to impact the
artifactory and confuse artifactory we are trying to confuse uh the package manager themselves and the
cli to install the packages and so that's an area of research of depi that we are doing a lot trying to
find those zero days of misconfiguration there's so many two of these package managers there's you
know npm yarn pnp just goes on and on and on um crazy wow yeah there's a lot of attack surface there
well definitely i am super looking forward to uh seeing the results of your research continued
research on this stuff with depi yeah lupin it seems like you're doing an excellent job and i
you know it's pretty great that i haven't seen any other major competitors doing what you're doing
here um so it's cool to see you sort of leading the the charge with this yeah and i think uh it's also
great to have you as a bug bounty hunter because we get the the sort of from an experienced bug bounty
hunter perspective of how we can apply this sort of supply chain vulnerabilities to bug bounty so um thanks
for coming on the pod and talking about that yeah thanks a lot for the the invitation uh it's always super
great to to talk with you indeed indeed thanks so much man um anything else you want to shout
obviously we've got depi uh that's at what is it l and h dot and tech yes lnh.tech uh slash depi you
can find more information about the tool there yeah um anything else you want to shout before we end the
pod yeah i really want to shout out uh to the entire french team in the hacker one world cup uh get out of
here no cut it cut it cut it off i just want to say those are crazy people finding crazy vulnerabilities
and uh amazing talents amazing young people new in the field and just breaking the biggest companies
in the world so i'm just impressed and amazingly surprised by all the talents uh that we have in
france uh and yeah vive la france oh my gosh all right let's go cut the pot here let's let's go and
that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking thanks so much for listening and if you want more
critical thinking content head over to ctbb.show slash discord join the discord there's lots of great
conversations and chats going on over there and if you want to support the show there's the discord
subscriber tiers which give you access to master classes amas hack alongs exclusive scripts and an
exclusive chat channel with us we'll see you there